Allison holker Mourns her late husband
Stephen twitch boss we love the Full
House and also just like family man like
honestly they're my favorite they're my
favorite people you know what I mean the
dancer returned to social media for the
first time since his death last week and
shared this sweet photo of them together
she writes in the caption my one and
only oh how my heart aches we miss you
so much whether it's um outside dancing
or or cooking a meal or even just
sitting down you know watching something
with our kids we do a lot together so
when it the things that we document it's
like a lot of that we're already doing
together and have been for a while it's
been over a week since Allison confirmed
turned twitch's death he was found in a
motel room not far from their family
home where he took his own life
ET learned twitch left a note behind
indicating that he couldn't go on
before twitch died the couple had big
plans for the future she has the vision
so once it comes together I'm like yeah
you know what you were right deadline
reports that Allison and twitch had
multiple TV projects in the works many
of them at HGTV you know any job that I
do or any work that I create typically
if we you know we either do it together
or if we don't I'd go to him he's the
first person to go to for you know
what's your advice what do you think
about this so I trusted I trust has got
a hundred percent in the wake of
twitch's death the network says in a
statement it's taking the time to
consider different scenarios
but for now their main priority is
supporting Allison and their children on
top of a home renovation series the two
were also reportedly exploring a dance
competition a game show and a variety
show we just kind of GrooVe and it just
comes it comes together for now Allison
is grieving twitch's devastating loss A
source told E.T that the pro dancer is
beside herself and it feels like she's
living a nightmare quote twitch was such
a genuine and good-hearted person and
his loved ones are feeling his
tremendous loss among twitch's loved
ones his mother Connie and never take
for granted the moments that I can make
my mom proud
Tuesday night Connie shared this
screenshot of a FaceTime with her son
she wrote alongside it oh if only I
could Face Time To Heaven followed by a
blue heart and a broken heart emoji and
at the time of twitch's death Connie
thanked her family and friends for all
the love prayers and encouragement quote
I can't use words right now please know
I will reach out when I can please
continue to keep us in prayer Stephen
Laurel your mother loves you to Eternity
and Beyond
foreign
[Music]